Hello everyone, and welcome to this introductory class on Twinmotion.
My name is Amea Yassine and I will be your guide today.
Today we'll look at Twinmotion, a real-time visualization tool based on Unreal Engine.
Twinmotion was originally developed as an architect's tool, but has developed since to cater for other markets.
You'll experiment with a typical workflow, first by ingesting data into Twinmotion.
You then learn to add context and embellish the scene with the help of an extensive assets library.
This enables you to add materials, characters and vehicles among other things, using a very easy and intuitive workflow.
You'll also learn to create and store your own user library, which you can then use across other projects.
You'll learn to create and scatter vegetation for a more natural environment.
Once you have finished this course, you may opt for a follow-up class that teaches you other tools in Twinmotion.
These include creating and adjusting man-made lights for night scenes,
as well as outputting media to disk in the form of images, panoramas and videos.
But first things first, let's start with the basics.